I'd like to welcome everybody to reasons
DC headquarters thank you for coming out
to our recent TV viewing party of the
john stossel ABC News 2020 special
bailouts of all why he put the magazine
for the first time I don't know why I
would pick it up I was just one for
stuff to read and I was amazed cuz
everything I read the magazine like oh
that's the way I what's the message the
thing I got out of that reason magazine
really helped me out is not thinking of
the government first for the answer to
every single problem over the past 10
years Oklahoma is at a universal
preschool program and they've actually
seen their test scores fall so if
universal preschool is going to provide
this magic benefit to improve education
we aren't seeing it works in place our
immigration policy should be driven by
the economic and emotional needs of the
American people not the social
engineering designs of America's
bureaucrats we should not have to
explain to the government why we are
bringing somebody into the country the
government should have to explain to us
why we should not isn't it true though
that if we sell toll roads or lease them
to foreign companies that they'll take
the toll roads back to wherever they
come from I know the estimates are
anywhere between 200 or 400 billion
billion dollars in private funds that
are ready to invest in the united states
that the spending under Bush was
something that we had not seen you know
I mean pretty much ever at this essence
LBJ let's bill since LBJ politicians
being hypocritical on anything let alone
the drug issue i think is something that
I've come to live with for the 14 years
that I've been running the Marijuana
Policy Project we just take it for
granted that it's not just presidents
but also members of Congress state
legislators governors and so forth to
think that there's different rules that
apply to them thank you for supporting
reason and all of its various guises
thank you all for coming out and we look
forward to carrying the conversation on
even more thanks